you
Michael Jackson's death unleashed a
flurry of media stories about all
aspects of the Popstars life including
his alleged prescription drug abuse his
prescription drug use and alleged abuse
Popstars possible drug use the popstar
was taking a combination Demerol vicodin
dilaudid xanax on the same day countless
millions watched Jackson's star-studded
memorial service recent TV interviewed
another musician this song is by Sean
Clark Redman a man who enjoyed an active
life before the neurodegenerative
disease ALS often referred to as Lou
Gehrig's disease rendered him nearly a
mobile he can no longer even play the
piano the disease also left him in
nearly constant pain at times the pain
can go so deep it feels like you know
it's right down to the bone unlike
Michael Jackson Redmond admits to having
a problem with pain medication however
his problem is very different than the
one that King of Pop is rumored to have
had since Michael Jackson's death we're
learning more about rampant abuse
Redmon's isn't the overdosing problem we
hear so much about this is under dosing
ribbons caretaker and partner Steve
Altman says Redmond is prescribed some
medication but not nearly enough to keep
his pain under control it's just so
frustrating and stressful to watch him
in
and know that there's a there are forces
behind us that don't want him to get the
medication he needs when he doesn't have
the medication it's hell I want to die
you know I just wanted to die chronic
pain in America is an enormous Lee
undertreated disease it's a public
health disaster dr. Frank Fisher is a
Harvard trained physician he says
Redmon's plight is an appallingly common
one instead of receiving the medication
they need millions of Americans suffer
needlessly according to Fisher and other
pain specialists consider nursing home
residents according to findings
published in the Journal of the American
Medical Association 41 percent of them
endure severe chronic pain how could
that be because law enforcement
interferes with the doctor-patient
relationship making doctors fearful of
prescribing high doses of opioids
when a patient develops severe chronic
pain basically there's only one class of
medications that's going to work s
opioid analgesics oxycontin Demerol
vicodin in other words the same pain
medication so often associated with
celebrity overdose and addiction
well these celebrity cases are
propaganda they don't reflect the
problem with these drugs in America
fisher practices medicine far outside
the hollywood paparazzi zone in the
Northern California town
he has no celebrity clients as he's done
throughout his career he treats mainly
poor people poor people are already
suspected of being drug addicts and
criminals and so are the doctors that
treat them with controlled substances
Fisher should know I was arrested when a
SWAT team of about 20 law enforcement
officials descended on my clinic at 9:00
in the morning dr. Fisher was thrown in
jail and charged with drug trafficking
and because some of his patients died
with pain medication in their systems he
was also charged with five counts of
murder they were trying to give me 256
to life and that's pretty hair-raising
to be sitting there looking at that sort
of thing the murder charges were thrown
out after investigators determined that
his patients deaths had nothing to do
with the medication Fisher prescribed
eventually all charges against Fisher
were dropped but not before the doctor
spent five months behind bars and years
fighting to get his medical license back
ten years on he's still struggling it
cost everything I had to defend myself
and whatever I could borrow and this
point I'm 56 years old and I'm starting
over and I have a net worth of zero
what causes doctors to worry about cops
and jails when they should be focused on
treating patients what we're dealing
with as a mass insanity we call it the
war on drugs the United States isn't
supposed to be a war with itself Altman
blames the drug war for the ongoing
fight he wages with doctors to get
Redmond the medicine he needs they're
afraid if they write that prescription
oh my god they're going to get locked in
jail they're going to get put away it's
true that most doctors don't get
prosecuted
it only takes a couple here and there
and that keeps the rest of the
physicians in why the harder they clamp
down the harder it is for me to live
with this disease recently President
Obama's drug czar announced that he
wants a law enforcement to strengthen
its monitoring of those who used
prescription drugs for reason TV I'm
Nick Gillespie said we'll come to you
often times not why
got a story of some man
next